Musik
So liebe Leute, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-UFO-Folge 9. Ich freue mich, dass Sie wieder da sind. Ich habe ein Problem, und zwar ist mein Startvolumen voll. Und deswegen kann es gut sein, dass wir zwischendurch einen Cut setzen müssen. Ich habe eben sämtliche wichtige Dateien des letzten Jahres von meinem PC runtergelöscht. Moderieren auf Messers Schneide, heute im Podcast UFO. Oder, wie Leute das schon genannt haben, UFO. Das ist übrigens sehr dämlich. Unser Podcast wurde schon UFO genannt. Nein, wir sind nicht der Podcast UFO. Es ist auch gut, seine einzigen Zuhörer zu beleidigen. Das ist wirklich selten dämlich. Um dann noch mal weiterzumachen bei der Beleidigung. Es hat jemand geschrieben, wenn jemand Florentin Will gut findet, dann hört euch seinen Podcast an. Das ist sehr nett. Um dann zu dem Entschluss zu kommen, dass er gar nicht so geil ist. Aber ich finde, das ist irgendwo ein relativ offensichtlicher Hinweis, dass wenn du sagen würdest, hey, du findest die Beatles gut, dann geh auf ein Beatles-Konzert. Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Okay, da werde ich jetzt auch selber drauf gekommen. Mein Gott, tut mir leid, dass ich jetzt schon wieder anfange, um die Zuschauer zu verleidigen. Das ist doch der einzige Gag, den ich mir vorbereitet habe.
Der ist jetzt raus, jetzt hängt es an dir. Ich habe noch eine Geschichte zum KFC, ansonsten ist diese Folge wieder ein absoluter hoffnungsloser Hoffnungsschimmer, das funktioniert einfach nicht. Warum eigentlich nicht? Wir haben beide Tweets am Laufen, das ist die schlechtmöglichste Situation, gerade jetzt einen Podcast aufzunehmen, wir haben beide gerade Tweets rausgehauen, wir sind beide geltungsbedürftige Arschlöcher, die alle fünf Minuten schauen,
wie viele Favorisierungen ihr Tweet jetzt
schon hat. Und es wird einfach nichts. Wir sind einfach
komplett abgelenkt. Ich habe weiterhin eine Favorisierung
von dir.
Ja, deswegen bist du auch so schlecht drauf,
deswegen konzentrierst du dich auch gerade auf dem Podcast.
Ganz kurz, ich möchte den Tweet kurz mal vorlesen.
Ach Leute, ich brauche keine
Interventionen, das war in Anführungszeichen,
Menschen, die Interventionen brauchen. Das ist von der Struktur her schon viel zu kompliziert, das verstehen die Leute nicht. Er ist aber nicht mein bester Typ. Wer hat das gerade gesagt, das funktioniert einfach nicht. Ach Stefan, weißt du noch damals, als wir uns gegenseitig Streiche gespielt haben? Toll, als wir hier angefangen haben im Podcast-Business. Ich meine, was soll ich sagen? Stefan Titze schaut mich hier an mit so einem Hundeblick. Du warst eine Stunde zu früh im Studio. Vor einer Stunde bist du hier reingekommen. Dann wärst du da. Erstmal, du siehst den gesamten Kaffee weg. Wir sehen uns gar nicht, dann haben wir kein Studio. Du hast den gesamten Kaffee weggeschüttet, den ich gestern noch gekauft habe. Du kannst mal bitte aufhören, immer an mich einzulabern. Du hast den Kaffee weggeschüttet. Wir laufen jetzt seit fünf Minuten ununterbrochen ineinander rein.
Nein, nein, nein. Du hast den Kaffee weggeschüttet, den ich gestern gemacht habe, sitzt hier seit einer Stunde im Studio, langweilsdicht, führt das irgendeinen schlechten Scheiss raus, habt ihr nichts damit zu befürchten.
Unser heutiges Thema, liebe Leute. Das war eine Frage, eine Frage. Bist du Banksy?
Ich will jetzt eine Antwort drauf haben.
Dammit!
Ich will jetzt eine Antwort drauf haben. Man muss auch Ja sagen, wenn man Banksy ist und man gefragt wird, muss man Ja sagen.
Und da werden wir auch schon mal ein Thema. Wir haben heute sehr doll ineinander rein, weil wir anscheinend einen Delay haben. Nach Berlin hat man einen Delay. Das ist okay, das ist okay. Ja, ja. Ja, ja. Marino Mines.
Ich rapp so krass, meine Rhymes haben Delay.
Du nicht, aber das ist okay.
Übrigens, wir haben vor, bald unseren nächsten Podcast zu starten, und zwar ein Freestyle-Rap-Podcast,
wo wir zusammen mit einer noch unangekündigten Person, Antoine Monod, versuchen werden, den Rap-Olym zu erklimmen.
Und das wird grossartig. Also stay tuned, wie man so schön sagt.
Das ist ein Problem. Podcast, wo wir zusammen mit einer noch unangekündigten Person, Antoine Monod, versuchen werden, den Rap-Olymp zu erklimmen und das wird grossartig. Also stay tuned, wie man so schön sagt. Das wird grossartig. Also du bist ja, bist du eigentlich als Werbeträger relevant? Siehst du dich als Werbeträger? Nein, noch gar nicht. Du, du bist ja, also ich sehe das Podcast-Ufo, sehe ich als Werbeträger. Ich finde, wir sollten ja öfter auch mal Werbung einstreuen, aber ich selber, mich persönlich, Ich sehe mich nicht als Werbung. Jeder mediale Output ist ja eigentlich nur dafür gemacht, um Werbung zu tragen. Es ist ja eigentlich alles nur eine Farce. Es ist ja alles nur, das ist wie so ein Kind, dem du irgendwie so einen Schokoriegel zeigst. Sicher, dass du das Wort Farce richtig benutzt hast? Und dann steckst du da so einen Brei rein. Was habe ich fast benutzt? Das Wort Farce. Hast du es eben im richtigen Kontext benutzt? Ja. Ich wollte nur mal Dinge hinterfragen. Das ist meine neue Art. Der neue Stefan hinterfragt Dinge. Aber es ist okay. Aber ganz kurz, also wenn jetzt Samsung zu dir kommen würde und dich fragen würde, hey, hast du nicht Lust, das neue Samsung Xperia 228, 180 Grad zu promoten? Dann würde ich dem Samsung mal mit meinem iPhone in die Fresse schlagen. Aber hättest du dann nicht Angst, dass das Samsung zu schnell und einfach zu benutzerfreundlich ist? Würde das nicht Angst machen? Würdest du nicht sagen, dieses Smartphone ist einfach zu gut, zu fortschrittlich, als dass ich dafür Werbung machen kann? Oder wie würdest du es angehen? Das ist eine gute Sache. Ist man zu gut für das Produkt, was man gerade Werbung macht? Nee, ist das Produkt zu gut für ein? Genau, sorry. Dass ich einfach sagen, hey, ich bin ein Riesenfan von Milka, ich glaube nicht, dass ich dieser Herausforderung gewachsen bin. Ich glaube, ich bin nicht das richtige Gesicht dafür. Ich bin weder Lila noch eine Kuh. Die lehnen wirklich Werbedeals ab, weil sie zu sagen, ich bin nicht gut genug dafür. Sehr gut. Ja, nee, weiß ich nicht, kann ich noch nichts zu sagen. Das ist auch gut. Also wir haben ganz kurz, wir müssen von vorne anfangen, Florian, wir müssen die Leute mit ins Boot holen. Wir haben uns heute folgende Themen überlegt. Thema eins, ja. Thema zwei, nein. Und da, das ist eine gute Sache, das habe ich auch schon mal gesagt, irgendwann, wenn man Podcasts macht und du stellst eine Frage oder der andere stellt eine Frage, einfach immer Nein sagen. Das ist sehr lieb, um das Gespräch anzukurbeln. Damit der andere einfach auf Trab bleibt. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, also wenn mir jemand einen Werbedeal anbieten würde, wäre das glaube ich meine erste Reaktion. Du wurdest kalkiert immerhin. Soweit ich weiss nicht, Aber was wir mal hatten, wir haben mal irgendwie so aus Spaß eine Werbung gedreht für einen grossen deutschen Werbe-Autohersteller. Und dann hieß es halt so, hey, werdet gerade Zeit, in der Werbung mitzuspielen, ihr dürft einen, ich sage jetzt mal, AMW fahren. Ihr dürft in AMW fahren, wer hat Bock? Da ich gerade nichts zu tun habe, bin ich mitgefahren, bin da irgendwie durch die Gegend gefahren und dürfte auch so cool zu leiden und so in dem AMW. Und dann wurde das irgendwie veröffentlicht, die Werbung irgendwie, AMW wollte es nicht. Und dann waren wir am nächsten Tag irgendwie bei Journalistenschülern eingeladen, um so unser Projekt vorzustellen. Und dann fragt einer dieser investigativen Hochjournalisten, ja, Herr Will, wie ist das denn? Sie haben jetzt Werbung gemacht für AMW, können Sie sich denn mit dem Konzern überhaupt identifizieren und wie sieht das überhaupt für Sie aus, nicht als Marke? Und ich bin da total in Bedrängnisse gekommen, wo sind ja, ich weiß nicht, die machen ja auch, klar, jetzt mit dem Ölleck und so im Meer und so und hier und da. Also es war eine Katastrophe. Ich meine, man muss aufpassen, Werbung ist ein heißes Eisen. Da sind Leute sehr emotional. Das ist auch so, ich glaube, dass Opel, Opel hat ja jetzt Jürgen Klopp lange als Testimonial gehabt. Und die sind ja auch lange sehr gut, Achtung, mitgefahren. Aber, aber. Aber ich glaube, er will bald aussteigen, oder? Ich glaube, er will ausgestiegen werden von Opel. Oder er legt noch einen Gang zu. Es ist nämlich so, dass Dortmund jetzt ja … Du bist ja kein Fussballfan, ne? Du redest zu schnell, drück mal auf die Bremse gerade. Du bist ja kein Fussballfan, oder? Nein. Nein. Und deswegen ist es ja so, dass Dortmund, weil die ja gerade relativ schlecht dabei sind, wenn ich so langsam rede, dann denke ich auch zu viel darüber nach. Ich kann nur so schnell reden. Das ist kein gutes Zeichen, man muss eigentlich schnell reden, damit man nie in die Möglichkeit kommt, eine innere Zensur anzuwerfen. Darf man gar nicht. Das stimmt, das ist mir echt aufgefallen beim langsam reden. Aber es ist so, ich glaube, dass Opel sich an einem gewissen Punkt geärgert hat, dass sie Jürgen Klopp genommen haben, weil er jetzt nicht mehr für Erfolg steht. You know?
Stimmt, das ist ein guter Punkt. War das nicht genau so, hat nicht irgend so ein Konzern Ootello oder irgendwie sowas sein gesamtes Marketingkonzept auf Bruce Darnell ausgelegt? Irgendwie Ubuntu, der ist die Wahrheit oder irgendein Schwachsinn? Innerhalb von 18 Minuten nach dem Ausstrahlen der Werbung kannte niemand mehr Bruce Danell.
Und es war einfach nur noch lächerlich.
Aber sie hatten halt auf allen ihren Firmenwägen, auf allen Grossen, auf ihrem Hochhaus, Grossstehen, Okomoko, der ist die Wahrheit.
Und es war auch, glaube ich, danach gab es noch eine Firma, die sich nur, also die ganze Marketingmaschinerie, diese Milliarden Euro Marketingbudget nur in Bruce Darnel gesteckt haben. Ja, so grosse Pappaufsteller, die man jedem Kunden mitgegeben hat. Und alle, die die Firma bis dahin kannten, sind von der Unbekanntheit von Bruce Darnel, haben die auch gleich den Namen der Firma vergessen. Du hast ja mal ein Jahr lang in einer Telefonzelle gelebt, wie war das so? Wie war das so, wie warst du da so aufgelegt? Du warst doch DJ, wie warst du so aufgelegt? Genau, du warst ja DJ, wie warst du so aufgelegt? Sehr guter Gag. Kennst du Witzvariationen? Nein. Ich hab mal bei einem, also immer mit Anruf, ich hab mal bei einem DJ angerufen, aber der hat gleich wieder aufgelegt. Sehr guter Gag. Ich habe mal bei Weight Watchers angerufen, aber die haben nicht abgenommen. So, jetzt will ich noch drei hören, dann bin ich beeindruckt. Ich glaube, ich habe mich dann... Aber warte, genau, ich habe mal in, ach wie heißt dieses Scheissland, ey. Okay, ähm, fuck it, war das, nee, nicht Peking, warte, warte, warte, genau, ich habe mal in, ach wie heisst dieses scheiß Land, ey, ach fuck jetzt, war das, nee nicht Peking, warte, warte, warte, die Geografie kennen. Hongkong. Nee, genau, ich habe mal in Tibet angerufen, war aber besetzt, weißt du das richtige Land, ich weiss es nicht. Es könnte auch falsche Land sein. Ist egal, der Inhalt den Gag. Es geht nur um den Gag und der Inhalt und die Satzschreibung, wie wir bei dir eben auch erfahren haben. Du hast nämlich im Geheimen verraten, dass wenn die 140-Zeichengrenze bei Twitter erreicht ist, dass dir dann sowohl die Satzzeichen völlig egal sind, als auch du schreibst nur noch Wörter falsch, Hauptsache der Gag kommt an. Ja, ich glaube, das ist aber auch der Grund, warum viele junge Leute nicht so gut in Rechtschreibung sind, weil sie einfach dieses Twitter-Syndrom haben. Sie müssen einfach alles so kurz wie möglich schreiben. Das ist auch der Grund, warum Klassenarbeiten nur noch 140 Zeichen lang sind bei den meisten Fällen. Das war ein Mördergag, das war ein Mördergag, da kann man auch mal lachen. Wir haben heute ein sehr starkes Delay. Ich habe dir tatsächlich gar nicht zugehört. Ich habe nur von der Melodie deines Satzes gehört, dass es ein Gag war und musste lachen einfach. Das reicht oft auch einfach schon so. Wir haben heute ein sehr starkes Delay und ich glaube, das demotiviert einen auch ein bisschen, wenn der Mitmoderator immer erst sehr spät lacht und man weiss gar nicht mehr, ob das jetzt noch auf den Witz bezogen war. Aber kennst du das, wenn man bei Starbucks ist und dann wollen die deinen Namen wissen und dann schreiben die aber einen ganz anderen Namen auf deinen Becher? Ja, toll. Oder? Oder dass zum Beispiel bei Starbucks heisst der kleinste Becher tall? Hä? Was soll das denn heissen? Tall heisst doch gross. Was machst du da gerade? Hast du gerade deinen Gag-Ordner
gefunden? Oder zum Beispiel, ich finde, wer aufs Smartphone schaut den ganzen Tag, der verpasst sein ganzes Leben irgendwie. Ist mir aufgefallen, dass Segways wahnsinnig komisch aussehen? Ja, ist mir aufgefallen tatsächlich.
Oder Fische. Sind Fische nicht lustig? Ja, oder Aale. Ich meine, ich dachte mir, der Vorteil vom Älterwerden ist, dass es immer unwahrscheinlicher wird, dass man von einem Aal getötet wird. Oder? Also als einziger Vorteil, das ist doch so. Ich meine, je älter du wirst, desto höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du stirbst, oder? Ja, aber desto weniger ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du jung stirbst, zum Beispiel. Nee, aber je älter du wirst, desto höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du an Altersschwäche stirbst, oder? Ja. So kann man es machen. Das kann man so machen, ist es aber auch nicht so die Erkenntnis, wo man sagt, wow, wo man als Podcast-Hörer alle seine Sachen niederlegt, die man gerade macht und kurz nochmal sagt, wow. Das heißt, mit jedem Tag, den man überlebt, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, eines unnatürlichen Todes zu sterben, höher. Das heißt, je länger man lebt, desto länger lebt man. Das ist das Fazit. Herzlich willkommen zur Best-of-Folge, denn egal was für Folgen wir noch aussauen. Ich bin gerade auf Witze.net. Du weisst, was mir letztens passiert ist? Ich habe meinen Zahnar im Bang-Bass getroffen. Hashtag awkward.
Das ist blöd, wenn man die sich schon als Tweets formuliert hat einfach.
Dann kann man die nicht so gut ins Gespräch einbauen.
Ja, weil sie nur 140 Zeichen lang tragen einfach.
War in einer Meinungsumfrage.
Wie unser Podcast von einer selbstkritischen, ironischen Vorzeigejournalismus-Schule geworden ist,
zu einem schlechten Runterrattern von Pointen.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Wie kommt denn das heute eigentlich?
Naja, wir sind gleich wieder da, wir sind gleich wieder zurück nach einer kleinen Werbung. Bis gleich, macht's gut. AMW. Zum zum. Kreatur d'automobile. Was auch der schlechteste Slogan überhaupt ist, einfach nur was man nicht versteht. Es war wahnsinnig einträgsam. Genau, was man nicht versteht, macht VW aber in Amerika auch. VW. Ist es auch das Auto? Das Auto. Wer soll das verstehen? Ja gut, aber Auto versteht man ja. Wer soll Auto verstehen? Niemand versteht es. Aber ich meine, wie schlecht müssen die Vorschläge für den Slogan in der Konferenz gewesen sein, dass man sich für einen entschieden hat, den niemand versteht. Ich meine, der Slogan ist schlecht, aber er ist immer noch besser als alle anderen, weil alle anderen versteht man und dann sind sie noch schlechter, als wenn man sie einfach nicht verstehen würde. Ich finde aber auch von Mazda dieses Zoom Zoom finde ich sehr befremdlich. Ja, aber da gab es doch mal so einen coolen Song, wo dieses Zoom Zoom dann eingebaut wurde. Ja, aber danach haben die halt ihre ganze Werbekampagne anscheinend so Bruce Darnell-mäßig nur auf diesen Song gestützt, das ist auch scheiße. Und Zoom Zoom ist auch nicht wirklich ein Geräusch, was Autos macht.
Brum Brum, will ich ja noch verstehen.
Oder Hub Hub.
Mazda, Hub Hub, finde ich sehr schön tatsächlich.
Hub Hub, Brum Brum.
Einfach genau am Objekt.
Man muss gar nicht gross zum Rum schlöseln, sondern man verkauft einfach nur Autos.
Schlöseln. Herzlich willkommen zu Wir erfinden Wörter der Neologismus-Podcast mit Florentin Will. Zniesel. Jetzt habe ich die Anmoderation gar nicht gemacht, oder? Haben wir eine Anmoderation gehabt? Nein, das war die Werbung, jetzt kommt die Anmoderation. Herzlich willkommen heute bei uns, wie hieß er noch gleich, hoffentlich ist er wirklich gekommen, Antoine Monod. Hey, Antoine Monod. Antoine Monod, hey, wie geht's dir? Oh, ich glaube, er hat kein Mikrofon. Ist sein Mikrofon an? To you. Ich glaube, sein Mikrofon ist nicht an, man kann ihn hören. Happy Birthday to you. Kann jemand mal kurz kurz schauen, ob Antoine Monod's Mikrofon an ist? Happy Birthday, liebe Antoine Mono. Happy Birthday, Daddy Lay, Antoine. Hat Antoine heute einen Geburtstag? Wir haben zumindest einen Fehler schon mal nicht gemacht, wir haben theoretisch nicht den Geburtstag vergessen, wenn er Geburtstag hat.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also es ist ein guter Tipp, wenn man Gäste hat, immer Happy Birthday singen, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist 1 zu 365, dass man den Geburtstag vergessen hat. Ach so, findest du es schlimmer, den Geburtstag zu vergessen, als den Geburtstag fälschlicherweise anzunehmen? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wirklich? Ich finde, Happy Birthday, das hat der Produzent, unser Produzent der Sendung, bei der wir beide arbeiten, gestern gesagt, dass Happy Birthday Du kannst Gags auch einfacher als deine eigenen raushauen. Das ist kein Problem. Ich habe gestern gesagt, den guten Gag gemacht, dass Happy Birthday von einer netten Geste immer mehr, je älter man wird, in eine peinliche Situation bringen geworden ist, oder? Muss man doch sagen. Ja, ja. Klassisches, wo soll ich hinschauen, soll ich mitsingen. Nee, mitsingen ist scheiße, mitsingen geht gar nicht. Ich glaube, das ist unter vollter Ordnung noch eins unter Waterboarding, ist den ganzen Tag Happy Birthday gesungen zu bekommen und nicht zu wissen, was man tun soll. Das ist schon sehr unangenehm. Ich bin immer so ein Mensch, ich habe ein sehr gut durchblutetes Gesicht und ich werde sehr schnell sehr rot und dann auch Leute, die sagen, wow, du bist total rot, fickt euch Leute, das hilft einem nicht, da rauszukommen. Das ist das Schlimmste, man weiß, dass man rot ist, wenn man rot ist. Genau, man weiß es, weil der Kopf ultra heiß ist und das Gehirn schmilzt zu heiß. Schreib das nochmal auf deinem T-Shirt, was eigentlich mit lustigen T-Shirts, wollen wir darüber reden? Lass mich nochmal, jetzt habe ich gerade eine Geschichte angefangen. Ah, okay. Sorry, sorry, sorry. So ist es ja gnadenlos. Ich glaube, wir haben die Anmoderation gemacht, ich weiß es gar nicht. Mach doch nochmal die Anmoderation, du machst auch so schöne Anmoderation, die hört man gerne zu beim Anmoderieren. Herzlich willkommen beim Podcast UFO, heute wieder mit heißissen Themen aus Natur und Umwelt. Wir schauen uns heute mal Stefan Titzes Liebesleben an. Bis gleich, jetzt kommt noch erstmal ein Song von Natasha Beddingfield. Heisst sie so? Bis dann, macht's gut, tschüss. Wir haben eigentlich noch keinen Catchphrase. Das ist auch als Radiomoderator gut zu fragen, heisst sie so? Ja, aber tatsächlich, ich würde gerne in so seriösen Medien mehr Emotionen sehen, oder auch so bei den Nachrichten so, das interessiert mich jetzt nicht so, aber okay, Gazastreifen, wieder acht Leute ermorden worden. Gazastreifen, heisst der so? Heisst der so? Mal kurz zu rechts gucken, wer hat sich diesen dämlichen Namen eigentlich ausgebracht, Gazastreifen? Gaba, ist das nicht anders? Ja. Kann gut sein. Kommt noch eine Zugabe von dir oder nicht? Nee, es kommt keine Zugabe mehr. Wie geht es eigentlich dem Fahrrad, das ich dir verkauft habe? Sind das diese neuen Impro-Comedy-Skills, die du gelernt hast? Dem geht es wahnsinnig gut. Ich fahre jeden Tag damit rum. Nur schade, dass ich, das ist ja ein Tandem. Schade, dass du alleine damit fahren musst. Kann man mit einem Tandem alleine fahren oder erstmal sieht es sehr traurig aus. Ich glaube schon, ist tatsächlich auch immer noch meine Vorstellung von dem lustigsten Auftritt aller Zeiten, irgendwie jeden Tag zur Uni fahren mit dem Tandem alleine. Weil man einfach beim Gebrauchtwagen-Fahrradhändler kein anderes Fahrrad sich leisten konnte als dieses scheiß Tandem. Ist es der lustigste Auftritt oder ist es der traurigste Auftritt? Sowohl als auch. Aber ich weiß nicht, was erbärmlicher ist. Einfach alleine fahren oder irgendwie so einen grossen Teddybären oder sowas hinten auf den anderen Sitzen setzen. So im Sinne von, haha, was für ein cuter Typ, hahaha. Oder ist es noch erbärmlicher? Oder ist es noch erbärmlicher, die ganze Zeit mit dem Bananenkostüm rumzulaufen. Einfach weil es das billigste war, was man gerade gefunden hat. Das stimmt, aber kommt tatsächlich immer gut an. Ich habe von einem Kumpel gehört, die waren bei Karnevar unterwegs und wahnsinnig gute kreative Kostüme angab. Und der eine, der die Banane war, war der, mit dem alle Fotos machen wollten. Warum? Man muss ja überlegen, was man sich bis zum Karneval anzieht, weil man ist ja nicht nur normal als Mensch unterwegs, sondern man macht ja gewisse Dinge. Man ist betrunken, man kotzt in die Ecke, man macht irgendwelche Frauen an. Und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, in welchem Kostüm sehen diese Handlungen besonders imposant aus. Ein normales Bananenkostüm, boring. Ein Typ mit Bananenkostüm, der sich übergibt, lustig. Das funktioniert besser als ein Darth Vader, der sich übergibt. Das ist nicht so lustig wie eine Banane. Weil vor allem, du musst auch den Helm abmachen. Du musst den Helm abnehmen. Ja, und dann bist du nicht mit Darth Vader. Du bist Darth Vader ohne Helm. Genau, und du hast dir nicht die Mühe gegeben, auch noch das Darth Vader-Make-up-up unterm Helm anzulegen. Und dann weiss jeder sofort, dass es eigentlich nicht alles meint. Gibt es dir nicht die Mühe, als Message-Ector zu sterben, weil Darth Vader stirbt ja, wenn er die Maske abnimmt. Ja, absolut. Sag mal ganz kurz, du bist ja eine Zitatkanone, ne? Also sag ich mal, du bist ja, du redest ja druckreif. Warte mal, das ist wie am Geburtstag so, von Leuten, wo man dann erfährt, dass sie einen gar nicht kennen, dann nehmen sie einen Dinge schenken, die man absolut nicht mag. Und das machst du doch, das machst du doch, oder genau das, was ich dir gerade geschenkt habe, magst du doch, nein! Das ist genau sowas, wie Leute einfach in den Schubladen stecken, ohne sie zu kennen. Ja, ja, okay, im Sinne des Podcasts bin ich eine wahnsinnige Zitatkanone. Ich wollte über ein paar Zitate von dir reden, die du im letzten Jahr so rausgehauen habt. Also um euch mal ein bisschen zu ersparen, dass ihr euch jetzt nicht, wenn ihr sagt, oh Folge 9 hat mir richtig gut gefallen, muss ich mir die anderen acht auch noch anhören. Nein, ihr müsst einfach nur hier die besten Zitate von Stefan Titzer rausholen. Ich habe meine Liste gemacht von den besten Zitaten, die Stefan Titzer rausgehauen hat im Laufe der acht Folgen. Und einfach nochmal, dass du da nochmal Stellung dazu nimmst, also was hat es genau bedeutet, wie bist du darauf gekommen, einfach nochmal ein bisschen ausführen. Machen wir quasi einen Audiokommentar zu einem Audiomedium. Genau, einen Live-Audiokommentar zu uns selbst. Das sollten wir immer machen. Einen Spiegel, einen Audiospiegel sozusagen. Lass uns mal, nämlich ist echt eine Folge, die wir irgendwie die dritte Folge oder so, also mal ein Audiokommentar zu aufnehmen. So dass vier Leute gleichzeitig reden und nicht nur zwei wie sonst. Und wir uns irgendwie auch selber fertig machen können. Ja, finde ich tatsächlich gut. Oder wir nehmen uns einzelne Teile raus. Und zwar hast du in Folge vier, glaube ich war es, das Zitat losgelassen. Ach, Folge vier. Wer erinnert sich nicht. Folge vier. Du hast gesagt, Schubladen sind nützlich in Schränken, aber blöd bei Menschen. Was hast du damit gemeint?
In erster Linie habe ich die Tiefe gemeint, die in Schubladen jedoch immer noch stecken und Schränke aus dem Schrank kommen.
Da war kurz die Verbindung weg.
Nein, das war sie nicht. Lieber zu schauen, war sie nicht, das ist ein schlechter Versuch. Da ist mein neuer Trick, wenn einem nichts mehr einfällt, zu sagen, oh, da war kurz die Verbindung weg, Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht verstanden, was du gesagt hast, ich habe nicht verstanden, was du gesagt hast. Man hat wieder wertvolle zwei Sekunden gewonnen, um nachzudenken, was man sagen will. Was versuchst du da gerade? Was versuchst du da gerade? Aber ist das für dich so ein Schubladen, bist du so ein Typ, der Menschen in Schubladen steht? Total. Also es ist sehr optisch bei mir. Also ich stecke viele Leute erstmal in diese optische Schublade. Also es ist quasi, was ich sehe, wenn ich so ein Nietenarmband sehe, dann stecke ich die schon mal in eine Schublade. Also alle Leute mit Nietenarmband, macht euch ja was gefasst, das ist schon mal eine Schublade bei mir. Und dann Leute mit Glatze stecke ich oft in eine Schublade. Also ich reduziere die erstmal auf optische Merkmale. Das ist mal meine erste Schublade. Hast du schon mal eine Person mit Glatze gesehen, die glücklich ist? Doch, Meister Proper. Ja gut, aber das ist ein Genie. Das ist auch geil. Der ist ja körperlos. How to make a podcast scheisse, in dem du sofort, wenn du so einen Geistensplitz hat, sofort mit einem Satz das entkräften. Nein, aber es ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage. Genie, also Meister Proper, hat ja keine Beine, von daher doppelt problematisch, behindert und glatze. Also schwieriges Thema schon mal in der Richtung. Aber ich meine, so als Genie, so wie bei Aladin oder sowas, der kann ja jede Gestalt annehmen, die er möchte. Warum entscheidet man sich für einen glatzköpfigen Typen als Meister Proper? Das war da der Entscheidungsvorgang. Wo kam das denn her? Warum nimmt, also meiner Meinung nach sind Glatzköpfe keine Sympathieträger. Ja, nicht, überhaupt nicht. Und deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum die Firma Meisterpropper sich einen Glatzkopf ausgesucht hat für Meisterpropper und nicht zum Beispiel Jürgen Klopp.
Aber wahrscheinlich damit er so schön glänzen kann, oder so als Zeichen für Sauberkeit und Hygiene.
Das ist ein tieferer Sinn, der aber nur dann Leuten auffällt, die sich aktiv in dem Podcast zum Beispiel damit auseinandersetzen und nicht…
Ja, aber dafür sind wir ja da. Ich hatte in der Schule mal einen Lehrer, der hatte eine Glatze und dessen Glatze hat so stark reflektiert, ich konnte ihn gar nicht anschauen. Ich habe mich so geblendet. Ich habe mich selber gesehen in seiner Glatze. Ja, genau. Das ist so, wie wenn, wäre doch total gut, wenn man irgendwie einen Spiegel auf dem Mond, auf dem Mond ist ja ein Spiegel, ne? Das heißt, wenn man in der Nacht mal hochguckt und winkt, kann man sich selber sehen, tatsächlich. Ich habe mir Folgendes gedacht. Aber das Licht braucht halt extrem lange, das heißt, du siehst dich vor 18 Minuten. Ich bin nämlich, ich bin kurzsichtig und Auto gefahren neulich, aber mit Brille, also aber ich wollte kurz mal diesen Spannungsmoment aufbauen, wo kurz alle rechtschaffenden Selbstjustizleute aus einem Hörerkreis kurz gemacht haben.
Es ist nämlich so, man guckt ja in den Rückspiegel ab und zu und ich bin kurzsichtig, das heisst, ich sehe Dinge verschwommen in der Ferne.
So, und wenn ich jetzt in den Rückspiegel gucke, habe ich mir kurz, bevor ich es getan habe, überlegt, was siehst du jetzt?
Unglaublich, wir machen ganz kurz Werbung, wir sind gleich wieder da. Bis gleich, macht's gut. Was genau sieht man da jetzt? Sag Bescheid, wenn wir wieder raus sind. So, jetzt sind wir wieder da mit Stefan Titzel und seiner Anekdote. Das war jetzt dein Ernst? Du wirst mich abwürgen, weil es nicht lustig mehr werden kann. Überhaupt nicht. Ich glaube, es kann nur noch lustiger werden. Es ist nämlich so, wenn man jetzt, der Spiegel ist ja nah. Das heißt, ich dachte, alles, was ich da, auch wenn ich kurzsichtig bin, der Spiegel ist ja nah, der ist ja kurz. Die Entfernung ist ja kurz. Also sehe ich alles, was ich da sehe im Rückspiegel, sehe ich das scharf oder nicht scharf? Ach, weißt du, Florian, den fick dich.
Du in der neuen Art, seitdem du karikiert wurdest und diesen blauen Haken hast und das zusammenspielt, bist du ein Riesenarschloch auf deinem großen Elfenbeinturm und guckst schnarchend und lachend auf uns herab, auf uns Volk. Du karikiert. Und es ist wirklich das Letzte. Und weißt du, du trägst dieses dämliche Eisen, diese Eisenkugel, die meiner Wenigkeit, die an dir hängt, trägst du mit. Das ist halt etwas, was du jetzt… Stimmt überhaupt nicht. Du bist wie Flügel für mich. Oh, Florentin. Seitdem du karikiert wurdest, bist du echt lustig. Oh, dankeschön. Das ist sehr freundlich von dir. Ja, und dann hast du den Spiegel gesehen und da hast du was, das hier… Es wird nicht besser. Ich dachte, du triffst bist so echt lustig. Oh, danke schön, das ist sehr freundlich von dir.
Ja, und dann hast du den Spiegel gesehen und da hast du was, dass hier... Es wird nicht besser, es wird nicht besser.
Ich dachte, du triffst in so einen Dialog mit mir und sagst, wow, interessante Sichtweise.
Das ist kein Dialog, das ist ein Abwimmeln.
Stefan, das, was du denkst, dass Menschen normalerweise miteinander reden, ist in der Regel, dass Leute dich einfach abstillen wollen.
Abstehen, Entschuldigung.
Vier Worte, vier Gedankenstränge gleichzeitig überschnitten. Das hat überhaupt nicht gut funktioniert. Da baut man manchmal einfach so Vorsilben ein, die überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben. Ich würde manchmal gerne in diesem Podcast in die Vergangenheit reisen und Dinge rückgängig gemacht haben, die ich gesagt habe. Ich würde in die Zukunft reisen, um darauf Bezug zu nehmen zu können, was wir gerade gesagt haben. Ja, um schlagfertig zu sein. Ja, genau. Ich habe gerade mir einen Tee gemacht und ich sauge gerade, der ist leer mittlerweile, und ich sauge an dem Teebeutel. Das ist wahnsinnig eklig. Bitte was? Ich habe gerade aus Versehen mal gemacht, es war eine Übersprungshandlung, ich habe eine Geschichte erzählt und dann wollte ich mich irgendwie dabei, ich habe immer gerne Dinge in der Hand, ob ich jetzt einen Kulli in der Hand habe und so und ich habe aus Versehen jetzt angefangen an diesem Teebeutel zu nuckeln. Aus irgendeinem Grund finde ich das total abartig. Ich auch. Obwohl es keinen Sinn ergibt. Es ist eigentlich, es schmeckt genau wie Tee halt. Es ist halt ein bisschen komisch. Ich schäme mich gerade für mich selbst. Aber manchmal denkt man sich schon, meine Eltern haben mich auch echt oft verarscht. Ja, das stimmt. Oder? Das Erste, was meine Eltern gesagt haben, also was ich sehr im Gedächtnis habe, sehr doll im Gedächtnis habe, dass Eltern nicht lügen.
Dass Erwachsene nicht lügen.
Ja, nie. Und immer die Wahrheit haben, immer Recht haben.
Aber das war selbst ja schon eine Lüge. Fickt euch, ihr Erwachsene.
So.
Heute einfach kein Argument, einfach Beleidigungen raus.
Ich erinnere mich noch an eine konkrete Situation, die ich ja wahrscheinlich komplett verdrehe, und zwar ist mir eine Breze in Abwaschwasser gefallen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja gut, ist nicht so gut gelaufen. Aber hat mein Vater gesagt, ja pass mal auf, Breze ist ja Laugengebäck und Abwaschwasser, also Seife, ist ja auch nichts anderes als Lauge. Also kannst du das noch essen. Und ich bin mir bis heute noch wirklich nicht im Klaren, ob das einfach Bullshit ist oder er mich einfach verarschen wollte oder ob das wirklich einen Hintergrund hat. Ich glaube, er wollte dich heimlich vergiften. Er wollte heimlich, dass du, ach komm, du warst jetzt drei Jahre am Leben und dann kannst du, ist ja immer gut, also ist ja immer wirklich gut jetzt.
Ich habe meinen Vater aber auch echt gequält, weil es war mein Hobby, immer irgendwie in der Küche zum Beispiel neue Soßen zu entwickeln. Es war immer meine Idee, weil ich dachte mir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Es muss doch die perfekte Soße geben. Ja, es kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass es nur Ketchup und Mayonnaise gibt. Warum gibt es nicht viel mehr Soßen? Oh Gott, oh, das tut mir so leid. Dein armer Haushalt, ihr habt nur bei McDonalds gegessen. Warum gibt es denn nur Ketchup und Mayo und süss-sour und Barbecue? Selbst McDonalds hat mehr Soßen als ihr. Und dann habe ich immer verschiedene ja, habe ich dann immer Soßen gekauft, irgendwie so eine Sandwich-Soße oder so und dann habe ich versucht immer zu mischen irgendwie und habe dann immer Gewürze reingetan und die dann irgendwie mit Wasser und so und dann draußen stehen gelassen und so und dann musste mein Vater das immer probieren.
Und ich danke meinem Vater sehr dafür, dass er dieses Hobby irgendwie immer weiter befreit hat und immer gesagt hat, das schmeckt so scheiße, Kind.
Das gibt's nicht.
Ja gut, da hat er recht, da muss ich auch was anderes machen.
Aber das gibt's nicht, das habe ich auch gemacht.
Wir hatten so einen Gewürzschrank und ich habe Wasser genommen, aber ich wollte keine Soße machen, ich wollte einen Gewürztrunk machen. Also ich wollte ein neues Getränk entwickeln. Da habe ich halt Wasser genommen. Das strangeste Kind der Welt! Sagt der, der das gleiche machen wollte, nur mit einer Soße. Ja, aber ich hatte zumindest ein konkretes Produkt vor Augen und nicht Gewürzwasser, was es nicht gibt. Ich auch, ich wollte ein Tränk getränkt machen. Und ich erinnere mich, ich habe alle Gewürze aus diesem Schrank, habe ich in dieses Wasser gekippt. Und am Ende hat es immer nach Curry geschmeckt. Das weiß ich noch. Weil Curry ist anscheinend das dominanteste Gewürz, was es auf der Welt gibt. Aber ich erinnere mich auch noch an eine Situation, wo mein Vater mich verarscht hat. Wir fallen schon wieder in dieses Kindheitserinnerung-Ding rein, aber egal. Wir haben unweit eines Altersheims gewohnt, wo öfter mal der Hubschrauber kommen musste, um einen sterbenden ... Um die alten Leute wieder einzufangen. Um die einzufangen, genau. So, aber einfach auch nicht in den Helikopter reingeholt, sie haben einfach so einen Haken unten gehabt am Helikopter und haben ihren Aufgeladen. So grossen Magneten. So grossen Magneten und der Herrschrittmacher ist dran kleben geblieben. Einmal über die Menschenmenge und Erna bleibt hängen. Da ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass Hubschrauber ja relativ unterschiedlich sind dem Flugzeug gegenüber, weil sie ja gerade landen, weil sie ja, sie landen ja senkrecht. Und man kann in diesem Altersheim, an diesem ... Scharf beobachten. Da gab es auch nirgendwo einen Platz, wo man hätte landen können, wie ein Flugzeug, sondern man kann halt nur genau senkrecht landen. Und dann war meine Frage, da hat mein Vater gesagt, ja, Hubschrauber, die müssen immer senkrecht, genau kerzengerade müssen die starten.
Und meine berechtigte Frage, wie ich fand, warum?
Und die Antwort war, da hat mein Vater offensichtlich nichts Besseres gewusst und hat gesagt, ja, weil die sonst explodieren.
Und ich habe relativ lange in meinem Leben geglaubt, dass Helikopter, wenn sie nicht Kerzen gerade starten, explodieren. Einfach direkt. Und wenn Helikopter mal so leicht schräg gestartet sind, habe ich immer gesagt, nein, nein, das geht nicht. Ich habe schon getraut um die Menschen da drin, aber es ist nichts passiert. Ich habe tatsächlich, ich habe immer eine Simpsons Comics gelesen als Kind und da gab es dann auch so Gewinnspiele. und ein Gewinnspiel war, man konnte irgendwie eine superkrasse Super Soaker gewinnen oder so, das Krasseste, was man überhaupt haben konnte als Kind. Und was man machen musste bei dem Gewinnspiel ist, man musste irgendwie den Sommerdrink entwickeln. Alkoholfreien Sommerdrink und dann das Rezept einschicken. Ich sagte ja, ich hätte den Tipp geben können, Curry. Curry ist super, Curry ist das Beste. und dann habe ich mir halt irgendwas ausgedacht irgendwie eine Zitrone ausgepresst und irgendwie dann irgendwie eine Gurke, Apfel oder irgendein Scheiss halt was überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat aber dann habe ich das aufgeschrieben das Rezept und habe gemerkt dass es halt zwei Zeilen lang ist so drücke eine Zitrone aus und tu Mineralwasser dazu. Da dachte ich mir, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gewinnen, die wollen wahrscheinlich mehr haben als nur zwei Zeilen. Und um das Ganze ein bisschen aufzustocken, um es ein bisschen mehr Volumen zu geben, habe ich dann immer noch so Routinen von Stelle das Wasser zehn Minuten in den Kühlschrank, hole es raus, tue die Zitrone acht Minuten in den Kühlschrank, hole sie raus, zerdrücke die Zitrone, stelle den Zitronensaft zwölf Minuten in den Kühlschrank und hole ihn raus. Bei Vollmond. Das war das einzige, was mir eingefallen ist, was man noch machen könnte, ist gewisse Zeiten einzubauen, die man in den Kühlschrank stellt, so wie in den Backofen, dachte ich halt. Und du hast gewonnen. So wie in den Backofen, dachte ich halt, könnte man es halt ein bisschen ummünzen auf den Kühlschrank. Und dann weiß ich noch, dann habe ich meinem Onkel das Rezept zur Korrektur gelesen, und habe gesagt, hey, was hältst du davon? Und mein Onkel die sehr berechtigte Frage. Das ist Bullshit. Ja, aber das mit dem Kühlschrank, also was soll das denn bewirken? Und ich weiß noch, wie ich mich so völlig lässig zurückgelehnt habe, so, ach ja, weisst du, manchmal muss man einfach ein bisschen mehr schreiben, damit sie es besser kaufen. Ich liebe es, wie Kinder manchmal so ein extremes Selbstbewusstsein haben können. Kinder sind brutal arrogant. Ja, erstens seinen Onkel es geben, um zu helfen und wenn er helfen will, zu sagen, ach nee, ich verstehe das besser als du. Das hat schon seine Gründe, die du natürlich nicht mal verstehen kannst. Aber mich würde immer interessieren, wer da gewonnen hat. Ich habe nicht gewonnen. Das habe ich mir noch fast gedacht. Aber eigentlich, wenn man die Sachen anguckt, an die Kinder ja kommen, im beides Küchenradius, dann ist es ja nicht so viel, dass man jetzt sagt, wow, da kann man ein mördermässig geränke finden jetzt. Das stimmt, ja. Oh, warte, ich habe gerade echt einen Panikmoment, weil es gut sein kann. Was? Okay, gut, okay, fuck, sorry. Ich dachte gerade, ich hätte mit dem falschen Mikrofon aufgenommen. Egal, Entschuldigung. Oh, go. Ich muss nochmal komplett aus dem Flow zu holen. Nochmal, tut mir leid. Jetzt muss ich erstmal kurz, die letzte halbe Stunde muss ich erstmal runterkommen jetzt. Nein, ich würde die Kindheit aber auch gerne hinter uns zurücklassen. Wir sind erwachsene Männer, wir haben anderes zu besprechen. Und wir haben Kommentare bekommen auf unserer Facebook-Seite. Lies mal vor. Könnt ihr auch immer gerne machen natürlich. Und zwar haben wir einen Kommentar bekommen von Jan P. und der schreibt, hallo, das Podcast-UFO. Leider ist mein rechter Kopfhörer defekt und mein Handy ist eine nutzlose Plastik-Krücke aus Fernost. Trauerger Smiley. Daher meine Frage, könnt ihr bitte die nächste Folge ein bisschen lauter aufnehmen? Ich kann euch sonst akustisch nicht folgen, aber vielleicht ist es auch ein inhaltliches Problem. Ich bedanke mich und wünsche euch einen schönen Tag. Ich kann nicht, ich Also, erstmal für... Oh, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam. Wir müssen uns Stück für Stück eingehen. Fangen wir vorne an. Wie ist denn bei den Anfang vor? Die ersten Satz bitte. Leider ist mein rechter Kopfhörer defekt, somit hört er dich nicht mehr. Ich bin links, du bist rechts, er hört nur noch mich. Er hat sich immer gewundert, wenn du da redest. Soll ich jetzt antworten? Was will der Mann von mir? Soll ich jetzt antworten? Telefoniere ich gerade? Ist auch gut. Bei manchem Podcast, weiss ich nicht, ob ich einen Podcast hören oder gerade telefoniere. Ich denke in Tweets, ich hau ihn jetzt raus. Hau ihn jetzt raus, hau ihn live raus. Nee, er ist nicht so gut, er ist nicht gut genug. Er ist nicht gut genug. Er ist nicht gut genug. Das ist Wahnsinn. Ich bin nicht Tweets. Hau ihn jetzt raus, hau ihn live raus. Der ist nicht so gut, der ist nicht gut genug. Der ist echt nicht gut genug. Der ist wahnsinnig. Der ist nicht gut genug. Aber vor allem, ich finde es so geil, dass er halt das schlechteste Setup der Welt hat und dann sagt, bitte macht lauter. Ich meine, natürlich versuchen wir alle Wünsche von unseren Fans zu erfüllen, klar, und wir können das machen. Ich meine, du kannst auch selber die Folge lauter machen, zum Beispiel mit iTunes, Rechtsklick, Informationen, kannst du es noch lauter machen.
Es gibt auch am Handy so Tasten, meistens sind die außen.
Du kannst tatsächlich nicht nur das Gerät lauter machen, damit alles lauter wird, sondern du kannst bestimmte Dateien auch lauter machen.
Am Handy steht meistens am außen ein Gerät, da steht Plus und Minus, da sind zwei Tasten nebeneinander, die sind nicht dafür da, dass dein Handy grösser wird oder die Schriftart grösser wird.
Dir ist schon klar, dass er dich nicht hören kann, ne?
Sondern es ist so, du kannst tatsächlich damit die Lautstärke lauter machen. Aber ich finde es so gut, dass er erst erklärt, dass er ein furchtbares akustisches Setup hat und dann sagt, ich kann euch sonst akustisch nicht folgen, aber, und jetzt kommt mein Lieblingssatz, vielleicht ist es auch ein inhaltliches Problem. Ja, danke. Mein rechter Kopfhörer geht nicht, ich habe schlechte Qualität, ich wohne neben einer Autobahn, ich kann euch kaum verstehen, aber vielleicht ist es auch ein inhaltliches Problem. Also danach sagt dann unser Fan, er hat geschrieben, euer Fan, weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich bin auch großer Fan von Jan, ganz ehrlich. Ich meine, natürlich haben wir massive inhaltliche Probleme, das ist uns schon klar.
Aber ich glaube, am wenigsten liegt es an der Lautstärke, die wir hier raushauen.
Tatsächlich glaube ich das auch, ja. Es ist wirklich so, die Lautstärke ist, glaube ich, das geringste Problem.
Also wenn du grosse Probleme haben sollst, Jan Peter, beziehungsweise Jan P, fuck, sorry, Zensur, Piep.
Und da wäre das inhaltliche Problem.
Ja, gut, aber die Pieps kann man sehr gut hören. Wenn es dir immer noch zu leise ist, dann ruf uns an, dann können wir dir alles nochmal erzählen, was wir gesagt haben. Oder wir kommen live bei dir vorbei und halten den nächsten Podcast. Das wäre auch mal eine Idee. Nummer 10, was machen wir eigentlich? Ich bin dafür, wenn ihr uns die Reisekosten erstattet, kommen wir zu jedem von euch Live-Podcast. Ja, aber sowas von klar.
Ja, natürlich.
Ach, heute ist es erst neun.
Das heißt, die nächste Folge ist die zehn.
Was machen wir eigentlich für die zehn?
Haben wir uns irgendwas Tolles ausgedacht?
Ja, wir machen eine Jubiläumsfolge.
Eine Best-of-Jubiläumsfolge, in der wir mit einem kleinen Sekt vielleicht beieinander sitzen und uns die besten Momente anhören und die live kommentieren, wie wir eben schon mal
angedutet haben.
Aber dazu brauchen wir natürlich eure Hilfe.
Was waren eure Lieblingsmomente aus dem Podcast-UFO?
Was waren die Peinlichstmomente?
Was waren die unangenehmste, welche Momente haben euch überhaupt nicht gefallen?
Schreibt uns eine E-Mail oder am besten einfach über Facebook, auch eine persönliche Nachricht, wenn ihr nicht wollt, dass wir euch öffentlich fertig machen.
Ansonsten können wir das vielleicht ein zacktechnischen Best-of schneiden und das ganze dann schicken an Nike, falls die vielleicht nicht sogar Lust haben, uns zu Werbepartner zu machen. Weil ich persönlich mag ja Adidas besser, lieber. Ich finde Adidas ist besser. Kauft Adidas. Wir machen so lange Werbung für Adidas, bis wir einen Werbevertrag mit Nike haben. Jetzt habt ihr es. Adidas-Sachen sind ähnlich gut, also qualitätsmäßig gut. Nee, aber ehrlich, so kann man nichts sagen. Ich habe kaum was... Ich habe auch noch nichts gehört, dass die Produktionsbedingungen jetzt so arg schlecht sind, wie bei anderen. Aber schlechter als bei anderen. Die sind generell ziemlich scheiße, glaube ich, bei solchen Unternehmen. Also, aber Adidas fällt zumindest nicht negativ auf. Wenn man das in der Werbung sagen würde, wäre auch echt gut. Unsere Arbeitsbedingungen sind scheisse, aber die Konkurrenten sind auch scheisse, wenn nicht sogar noch schlimmer. Ja, anderes Thema. Und zwar, ist mir was Lustiges passiert? Nein, nein, nein. Was ich sagen wollte, tatsächlich bin ich ein Typ, ich rebelliere nicht. Also überhaupt nicht. Also wenn ich mit einer Situation konfrontiert bin, mit der ich nicht zufrieden bin, dann ändere ich da nichts dran. Was machst du denn dann? Flüchtest du vor Situationen? Ziehst du dir was anderes an? Nee, ich flüchte nicht. Ich versuche zu improvisieren. Ich versuche, mich der Situation anzupassen. Anzupassen? What? Anstatt, dass die Situation an mir angepasst wird. Ja, ich passe mich eher an, als dass ich versuche, andere Leute an mich anzupassen. Zum Beispiel. Zum Beispiel, angenommen, du hast im Dritten Reich gewohnt. Ja, klar, ich wäre ein Vorzeige-Nazi gewesen. Sagt, hier, Freunde, der sieht aber nicht ganz koscher aus. Mach's gut. So was in der Richtung. Wer ist auch ein Comedy-Nazi? Gab's Comedy-Nazis? Gab's im... Natürlich! Natürlich gab's das. Klar! Ich glaube, ein Grossteil ihrer Politik ist bei einer guten Runde Comedy entstanden.
Ey Leute, wie saulustig wäre es halt, Russland anzugreifen.
Oder Russland, stellt euch das mal vor, das hat halt noch niemand geschafft.
Wie krass wäre es mit mir schaffen würde.
Irgendjemand hört das mit und denkt sich, Alter, machen wir, oder?
Gute Idee. Weiß nicht, ist ein hartes Thema, Comedy mit Nationalsozialismus.
Aber ist es eigentlich so, dass die dann auch damals, also gab es Comedyclubs zum Beispiel in der Nazizeitit, wo die auch wirklich selbstironisch gesagt haben, jetzt wäre es Zeit für ein Wortspiel. Okay, ich bin ganz ober. Heute bei uns als unser Gastapo, ne, ne, das war nichts. So, wir machen ganz gut Werbung, wir machen ganz gut Werbung,bung, wir sind da für Sie. Ciao! Lach doch mal ein bisschen, wir sind nicht im Konzentrationslager. Hier ist Mareike Amado mit Can't live without you. Viel Spaß. Tough crowd, tough crowd. Weißt du, wir kriegen es nach oben. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube nicht. Ohne Witz, ey, wenn es gut zu Ende ist. Ich habe gar nichts mehr, ich habe kein Material mehr, ich habe nichts mehr, ich habe keinen einzigen Gang mehr. Wir schwimmen, wir schwimmen mega. Wir können uns jetzt noch ein, wir können uns noch ein, wir total, ich habe nichts mehr und du liebst es mir auch nicht, ey, von dir kommt gar nichts. Doch klar, ich wollte eben diese Nazi-Geschichte erzählen. Ja, wir hauen uns noch ein Nazi-Gag raus und dann müssen wir irgendwie gucken, dass wir irgendwie in so ein Hörspiel oder irgendwie so einen Scheiss machen, um irgendwie echt Zeit zu ...
Ich kann die Worte nicht mehr, ich werde die Worte verloren. So, das war ein cooler Song. Ansonsten, falls ihr euch noch ein Lied wünscht, schreibt einfach auf unserer Facebook-Seite 080 22 10 oder ruft einfach durch, schreibt eine Postkarte an hfft. Schreibt eine Podcaste. Wir kommen aber jetzt nicht so schlecht. Ja, wir haben euch ein Wortspiel versprochen, Wortspiel Comedy und Nationalsozialismus.
Hier.
Man muss auch nicht alle Versprechen halten.
Doch, doch, hey kleiner Rolf, wo möchtest du denn mal dienen dem Deutschen Reich, wenn du gross bist?
Ich möchte in die Leibpointe Adolf Hitler.
Ja.
Also was ich sagen wollte, ich war beim KFC.
Ach genau.
Und ich habe mir bestellt, und zwar, ey, das finde ich aber echt lame.
Also muss ich dir jetzt mal echt ins Gesicht sagen, dass ich es lame finde.
Und zwar sind die so dreist, dass wenn man ab einem gewissen Alter das Kindermenü bestellt, kriegt man kein Spielzeug mehr. What? Das finde ich einfach eine Frechheit, weil die wissen ganz genau, dass es dir extrem unangenehm ist und du nicht sagen kannst, ja, aber da ist jetzt eigentlich kein Spielzeug drin. Das machst du nicht. Naja, das kann sagen, ist für einen Freund. Die wissen das ganz genau und deswegen wissen die ganz genau, dass sie einfach damit wegkommen, dir das Spielzeug nicht zu geben und das ist einfach scheiße.
Das ist für meinen kleinen Bruder, für meinen Sohn.
Ja, das ist mein Bruder, ich könnte ein Kind haben, hallo, ich könnte irgendein afrikanisches Kind adoptiert haben oder ich könnte irgendein somalisches Kind unterstützen und will dem Spielzeug Sachen schicken, hallo, was geht eigentlich mit euch ab? Ich habe wirklich, das war die schlechteste Bestellung beim KFC ever. Ich habe mir so ein Kindermenü bestellt mit Kartoffelbrei und einer Hähnchenkeule und ich habe nicht das Spielzeug bekommen, ich habe keinen Löffel bekommen für den Kartoffelbrei und ich habe keine Serete bekommen und das Getränk war nur zur Hälfte voll. Also das war echt eine Katastrophe, das war wirklich so das Stalingrad der KFC-Bestellung. Das hat mit dem KFC, das ich kenne, nichts mehr zu tun. Nichts mehr zu tun. Ich war schon 50 Mal mit dem KFC, es war immer warm und lecker, aber das nicht mehr. Und dann saß ich irgendwie draußen vorm Dom auf der Treppe und wollte meinen Kartoffelbrei essen, hatte aber keinen Löffel. Und dann habe ich mit der Hähnchenkeule den Kartoffelbrei gegessen. Das war so ein Moment, wo ich mir wirklich, wo ich kurz innegehalten habe. Ich hatte irgendwie eine komplett fertige Hähnchenkeule und Kartoffelbrei um den Mund und dachte mir wirklich, ist das mein Leben? Du bist eine Parodie der selbst. Ist es wirklich so weit gekommen, ich sitze hier vorm Dom, ich meine, da haben irgendwie Genies 500 Jahre lang dran gebaut, um den zu bauen und ich sitze hier auf der Treppe, besuche ihn irgendwie mit Kartoffelbrei, weil ich irgendwie versuche, mit einem Lebensmittel andere Lebensmittel zu essen, ich meine, was ist denn los? Das war so ein Moment, da musste ich mal wirklich kurz in mich gehen. Und das ging nicht gut aus, diese Suche. Du hättest auch so einen Hut vor dir hinstellen können, er hätte bestimmt noch Geld bekommen, weil er so traurig aussah. Einen Löffel bekommen, ja, Kartoffel bekommen. Vielleicht sollten wir mal eine Top-Five machen, der besten, Top-Five ist auch, glaube ich, eine gute Idee, hat auch noch niemand gemacht, glaube ich, der besten Fastfood-Ketten, der besten, der besten Franchise-Unternehmen, die wir kennen. Okay. Auf Platz 5 und, warte, wir brauchen einen Jingle, das sind die besten 5, die uns gerade spontan einfallen.
Und zwar, auf meinem Platz fünf wäre McDonalds.
Warte, ganz kurz, ich kann es ganz kurz nochmal eine Sekunde geben.
Was machst du denn?
Warte, ich muss mir die Liste schreiben, wieso hast du dir jetzt vorgestellt, dass ich die Liste vorlehr habe?
Ich wollte es spontan machen und bei eins was erfinden, weil wir kennen keine fünf. Aber was meinst du mit Franchise, also Ketten oder was? Ich weiß es nicht. Es war gerade so eine peinliche Stille, ich wollte einfach irgendwas sagen. Jetzt lag ich noch nicht auf was fest. Warte, ganz kurz. Ja, okay, leg los. Warte. Auf Platz fünf ja okay, leg los.
Warte, auf Platz fünf ist bei mir McDonalds. Bei mir auch. Auf Platz vier ist bei mir. Moment, wir müssen das ganz kurz mit McDonalds besprechen. Warum ist McDonalds bei dir nur auf Platz fünf? Ich will das unbegründet lassen. Ich will das unbegründet lassen. Nein, McDonalds ist immer noch lecker, aber auch irgendwie, ich traue dem ganzen Braten nicht mehr so. Seitdem ich mal gehört habe, dass man, ich habe mit jemandem gesprochen, der da gearbeitet hat, und es ist so, dass die da auch ganz oft in das Essen rotzen und sowas. Ja, klar. Und seitdem esse ich da nicht mehr so gern, aber halt manchmal dann doch noch. Ist bei mir tatsächlich auch so ein Thema, was Takeaway angeht, und zwar ob man beim Takeaway Trinkgeld gibt. Und ich stelle mir immer vor, also ich habe mir zum Beispiel heute Sushi geholt, habe ich ja schon erwähnt, und nur falls ihr vergessen habt, dass ich es erwähnt habe, habe ich schon erwähnt, also meine Geschichte ist ein handfesses Alibi, es ist nicht so, dass ich es jetzt um ihr erfinde, ich habe es tatsächlich schon erwähnt, es ist wirklich so passiert. Und da ist es immer so, dass man dann erst zahlt und dann sein Essen kriegt, crazy, und da weiss ich immer nicht, da weiss ich nicht, ob man da Trinkgeld geben sollte oder nicht, war eigentlich ja nicht, war eigentlich bezahlt mit dem Trinkgeld ja ein Service oder sowas, aber im Takeaway gibt es einfach keinen Service. Und deswegen denke ich mir aber jedes Mal, wenn ich kein Trinkgeld gebe, denkt er sich, der rotztz der einfach gnadenlos in meinem essen weil wahrscheinlich würde ich es auch so machen ja genau das ist auch immer was ich denke und wenn man aber dieses wenn man sehr wenn man so fantasievoll ist wie wir und sich so ganz komische dinge ausdenkt dann geht man sehr viel eigens durchleben und uns auch sehr man ist relativ schnell sehr arm weil man sehr viel auch bezahlen muss extra aber ich finde es mit dem trinkgeld ich finde es tatsächlich das amerikanische System sehr gut, wo ja irgendwie auf dem Kassenzettel kann man dann den Trinkgeld schon eingeben, Tipp, oder es gibt da ganz klare Konventionen, so und so viel Prozent Tipp und eigentlich sollte man dann immer auch noch mehr geben, als das, was eingehend ist, so als Bonus. Ja, nee, nee, nee, da hast du nämlich einen Preis. Aber nee, nee, nee, da finde ich es aber nämlich gut, dass man dann genau weiß, ah, das sind Gerichte, wo es und das sind Gerichte, wo kein Tipp erwartet wird, weil du ja auf der Rechnung schon die Vorhersage, sozusagen das Ausfüllformular stehen hast und du weisst, aha, das ist eine Interaktion, wo Trinkgeld erwartet wird, da kann ich noch Trinkgeld geben. Wobei ich beim Takeaway in Deutschland weiss das einfach nicht oder Friseur ist auch sowas. Hallo? Nein, niemals! Nein, ich dachte schon, jetzt bin ich echt total verwirrt. Da ich beim Friseur war, mit dem ich da war, habe ich gesagt, gibt mein Trinkgeld? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und da bin ich total hin und her gerissen. Niemals! Niemals! Nie! Oh Gott! Du meinst, Trinkgeld gibt man nur dann, wenn Service nicht die ganze Leistung ist. Bei McDonalds zahlst du ja das Essen, aber Service ist ein Bonus, also bezahlst du den als Bonuskonzept. Wohingegen beim Friseur gibt es nur den Service. Wenn ich beim Friseur bin und ich gehe da raus und sehe aus wie der junge James Dean oder so, und dann sieht die plötzlich wahnsinnig gut aus und hätte das vorher nicht erwartet, dann kriegen die Trinkgeld, dann kriegen die mein ganzes Portemonnaie, dann alles, was ich besitze, gebe ich denen. Ein flaches Portemonnaie kriegst du dann. Aber es wird soweit nicht kommen. Also die holen meistens aus mir das Nötigste raus. Und deswegen kriegen die auch nur das, was sie verlangen. Ich bin auch nie vom Friseur gekommen und habe gesagt, boah, du siehst es wahnsinnig gut aus. Ich glaube, es hat noch nie jemand gemacht. Nee, genau. Und nie ist jemand vom Friseur gekommen und hat sich gut gefühlt. Aber es ist auch schwer zu vermitteln.
Frisuren sind tatsächlich extrem schwer zu vermitteln, weil man hat einfach keine Standards. Man kann nicht sagen, ich hätte gerne einen Stufenschnitt hier und da, bla bla bla. Das hätte ich gerne wie bei Subway. Ich hätte gerne wie bei Subway, dass man sich da, dass man von voll, dass man jeden, dass man jeden, dass man jeden, dass man jeden Schritt überdenkt, überdenken kann, die Chance hat zu überdenken, den man quasi durchmacht. Also ich bin zum Beispiel einer, ich sage immer sehr detailliert, wie ich mir meine Frisur vorstelle. Und ich würde gerne so ein iPad oder so vor dir haben. Und dass du dann erstmal jeden Schritt, erstmal, willst du die Haare färben? Nein. Dann willst du eine kurze, mittellange Pferdeschwanz. Das ist sehr grob. Aber das könnte man auch eine Kette machen. Gibt es eigentlich eine Friseurkette? So ein Franchise? Das ist mein Platz eins. Aber das ist tatsächlich, ich glaube, das ist keine gute Idee, weil die Leute ja nicht genau benennen können, was sie wollen. Beim Subway kannst du sagen, mögen sie Tomaten? Nein, klare Antwort. Aber beim Friseur, wollen sie, dass man ihre Haare unter ihren Ohren noch sehen kann? Keine Ahnung, sieht das gut aus oder nicht, weiß ich nicht. Du kannst dich auch beraten lassen. Kommen wir zum Platz vier. Mein Platz vier ist Asado. Das ist so eine Steakhouse-Kette und da gehe ich ganz gern hin. Mein Platz vier ist Dominos-Pizza. Oh, ey, wir sehen uns ein bisschen.
Ich weiss nicht warum, ich habe da noch nie gegessen, aber das Logo gefällt mir.
Ich habe tatsächlich auch einen Dominus direkt bei mir um die Ecke, wirklich keine 50 Meter von hier, aber ich glaube die liefern doch nur, oder?
Ich glaube, da kann man gar nicht reingehen und essen, sondern die liefern noch, oder?
War das nicht so was? Wie gesagt, das weiß ich nicht.
Und vor allem, egal, Platz drei ist bei mir, oh shit, bei mir ist Platz drei und zwei dasselbe.
Dann ist Platz drei KFC, Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Ist tatsächlich bei mir so ein Ding, wo man sich wirklich...
Ist es abgerutscht durch deine letztliche Erfahrung?
Nicht ganz, aber ich finde KFC deswegen so gut, weil man einfach
sich auch nicht mal nur so tun kann,
als wäre das irgendwie vernünftiges Essen.
Das ist halt einfach nicht gut für deinen
Körper und das ist so offensichtlich.
Moment, das habe ich mir noch nicht eingeredet.
So weit war ich noch nicht.
Aber ich finde, man hat ja immer so einen inneren Zwist,
man weiss, es ist schlecht, aber man will es trotzdem haben
und dann gewinnt am Ende natürlich der Ich will es haben. Auf jeden Fall. Aber in dieser Argumentationskette gibt es dann so Sachen wie, naja, auf dem Big Mac ist ja auch Salat und das ist ja auch gesund. Und die Leute sehen alle so gesund aus auf den Plakaten von McDonalds und naja, das wird schon nicht so schlecht sein. Die Leute übertreiben ja auch oft. Und ich bin ja heute schon fünf Minuten mit dem Fahrrad gefahren, da habe ich ja die Kalorien von so einem Big Mac locker schon wieder drin. Ja, kein Problem. Ganz kurz mal, würde ich hier mal was einwerfen. Ich rede mir mal ein, dass ich sehr viel essen kann, weil ich auch viel nachdenke. Ich bin in einem Beruf, wo ich sehr viel nachdenke und ich habe mal gehört, dass das Gehirn am meisten Kalorien verbraucht.
Ich wollte es gerade sagen, diese Information, glaube ich, hat mich 16 Kilo zunehmen lassen. Das ist das Dümmste, was man Menschen sagen kann. Wenn du denkst, nimmst du ab. Okay, 10 Kilo zugenommen. Aber das ist das Dümmste, was man Menschen sagen kann, weil über nichts hat man so wenig Einfluss darüber, sagen zu können, ob man jetzt sich viel gedacht hat oder wenig an einem Tag. Das ist ja Schwachsinn, ob du Sport getrieben hast, kannst du ganz objektiv benennen oder kannst du sagen, ja gut, ich bin zum Büro gelaufen, manche die Bahn zu nehmen, okay, dafür kann ich mir jetzt ein 21er-Pack Chicken McNuggets holen, ja, klassische Argumentation, ganz einfach, aber dieses, das Gehirn verbraucht die meisten Kalorien katastrophal, wer auch immer das rausgefunden hat, verbiete das Wissen, vergrabe dieses Wissen, erzähl das niemandem, das ist schädlich. Und wenn es KFC steht, ja stimmt, ich musste heute überlegen, welche S-Bahn ich nehme, und dann habe ich noch mit dem Typen geredet, der Name ist mir nicht gleich eingefallen. Das sind so 800 Kalorien, nehmen wir mal einen Big-Netz. Es gibt auch diese Uhren, die messen, wie viele Schritte du gegangen bist. Wenn es das gäbe, wie viele Kalorien du mit dem Denken verbracht hast, wäre es total geil, wenn du die ganze Zeit mit so Elektroden auf deinem Kopf rumläufst. Hey Will, treiben Sie Sport? Nein. Aber ich denke sehr viel nach. Aber gibt es dann da wirklich Abstufungen, dass man viel denkt oder wenig? Weiß ich nicht, hat schon ein Arzt mal gefragt, die haben ja so eine Checkliste, haben sie Herzschluss machen? Nein. Treiben sie Sport? Nein. Rauchen sie? Nein. Denken sie viel nach? Hat noch nie ein Arzt gefragt. Ganz ehrlich zu sein, nein. Aber es hat noch nie ein Arzt gefragt, es sagt mir zum Beispiel, dass es nicht wirklich aktiv hilft, um abzunehmen. Ja, aber vor allem, was heißt denn denken, also angenommen, du spielst Schach, da kann man davon ausgehen, dass das Gehirn da sehr hohe Leistungen bringt. Hast du schon mal einen sehr dicken Schachspieler gesehen? Denkt da schon immer drüber? Stimmt, ja, guter Punkt, aber die kommen auch aus Russland. Naja, auf jeden Fall, aber zum Beispiel wenn man Sport treibt, denke ich mir, da muss das Gehirn ja auch viel leisten, weil es muss immer so Fuss nach vorne, Fuss nach hinten, Fuss nach vorne, die ganze Zeit ununterbrochen, da muss man ja, da denkt man, man denkt jetzt, man hat keine konkreten Gedanken vielleicht, aber das Gehirn arbeitet ja trotzdem. Ich glaube, das sind alles Automatismen, auch Gen zum Beispiel, da machst du ja nicht mehr aktiv Gedanken. Ja, aber konstant drüber nachzudenken, dass man nicht jetzt einfach aufhört und zum Subway geht, sondern weitermacht, da muss ich intensiv, also nicht, dass ich Sport treiben will, machen wir uns nichts vor, aber da muss ich intensiv darüber nachdenken und damit auch doppelt. Ist dir immer aufgefallen, dass wenn du aktiv darüber nachdenkst, wie du gerade gehst, also es sind Automatismen, aber wenn du darüber nachdenkst, sieht es total seltsam aus und hier hat immer so eine Phase, wo ich wirklich, da hat mir mal jemand gesagt, Stefan, du gehst ganz komisch, du gehst wirklich, also alle Menschen gehen normal, ich habe noch nie, aber du gehst wirklich komisch. Ja, das sind auch so Sätze, die das Problem noch schlimmer machen. Es macht dich furchtbar, seitdem habe ich darüber nachgedacht, da habe ich mal darüber nachgedacht und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich komisch gehe, aber es macht das nicht besser. Du kannst dann nicht sagen, okay, mir fällt jetzt aktiv auf, ich gehe komisch, ich stelle es genau jetzt ab und ab genau jetzt ist der Punkt, ab dem ich normal gehe, das geht halt nicht, du gehst halt weiterhin komisch und wenn es dir auffällt und du dir bewusst machst, machst du es noch seltsamer. Ja, das ist auch so mit Körperhaltung. Wenn jemand sagt, ey, du hast eine komische Körperhaltung, ab dann siehst du einfach aus wie so ein Hampelmann, der irgendwie so den Rücken durchdrückt oder so. Weil man weiss ja auch nicht, wie man sich richtig Körperhaltung... Wenn ich gerade gehe, sieht das ganz komisch aus. Wenn ich meinen Rücken durchdrücke, dann... Ja, du bist halt auch gross. aber ich glaube, da kann man ja auch vieles Selbstbewusstsein ablesen. Du bist sehr gross, läufst aber oft gebückt und da lese ich immer draus, du hast ein sehr geringes Selbstbewusstsein, weil du dich für deine Grösse auch schämst und eigentlich kleiner gern wärst. Wärst du gerne kleiner eigentlich? Ja. Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber ich habe eine sehr geringe Selbstachtung. Ich gucke in den Spiegel und denke, du bist verwachsen und gross und deine Nase ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen komisch. Um mal über das Stichwort verwachsen wieder zurückzukommen, bei KFC kannst du dir diese ganzen Argumente nicht bringen. KFC ist offensichtlich fett an dem Knochen, da kann man auch nicht lange drüber reden. Das sieht aus wie fett, das riecht wie fett, das schmeckt wie fett, wahrscheinlich ist es fett. Wir können davon ausgehen, man kann davon ausgehen. Und da gibt es nicht irgendwie, möchten Sie noch einen Salat dazu? Nee, ich nehme noch eine Hähnchenkeule, weißt du was? Keine Beilage, fuck it. Ich will einen Eimer und als Beilage noch einen kleineren Eimer. Aber beide Eimer sind randvoll geführt, einfach mit Huhn, einfach Fleisch, da gibt es einfach nichts anderes, einfach nur Fleisch. Und da kann man sich einfach nichts vormachen und deswegen finde ich es auch so geil, weil das so dieser Exzess von Fastfood ist, dieses ich esse maximal ungesundes Essen und das macht schon wieder gut.
Genau, das war noch im Serviet in so einem Eimer, in dem unfassbar ungesundesten Angemach, also wie man servieren kann.
Es gibt dafür gar kein Wort, man kann es nicht Geschirr nennen.
Es gibt im Deutschen kein Wort für Eimer.
Behältnis.
Gibt es einfach nicht.
Behälter, ja.
Dein Platz drei, oder waren wir schon bei zwei? Ich hatte schon KFC als Platz drei genannt. Scheiße. Mein Platz drei ist Applebee's. Was ist das denn? Applebee's, ich war mal in den USA, und da war ich in Applebee's und das hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Ach Gott, ich war mal in den USA. Ich bin Stefan Titzel, ich habe so eine tiefe Radioerzählerstimme. Ich war einmal, das ist auch so ein Ding, mich hat jemand auf meine Erzählerstimme reduziert. Menu, okay, Lunch, es gibt Sandwiches, es gibt Steak, es gibt Nachos. Die sind sehr netter, die sind vor allem mit da. Also vor allem in diesem einen Laden, wo ich war. Eigentlich auf Platz drei ist nur der eine Laden, der eine Laden. Wenn man dir die Kellnerin gefallen hat, sagst du jetzt, dass es auf Platz ... Die war sehr nett. Was ist das für eine uninvestigative Journalismus? Das war scheiße. Sie hat sich zu mir gesetzt, hat gesagt, hey, I'm Katie, I'm your waitress for the day. Und dann hat sie angefangen zu erzählen und ich hatte, glaube ich, die ganze Karte gekauft. Einfach weil es so nett war, wie wie sie es zu mir gesetzt hat. War ein bisschen aufdringlich, aber es hat mir irgendwann auch gefallen. Dein Platz zwei.
Mein Platz zwei ist Burger King.
Was? Tatsächlich immer mein, ja, immer mein Highlight.
Aber Team Wallraff.
Nein, Team Wallraff, ich finde, schau mal, ich finde, wir leben in einer Gesellschaft.
Ich habe jetzt schon abgeschaltet, wenn du anfängst, schau mal.
Hör mal zu, jetzt will ich mal wirklich was sagen. Wir leben in einer Gesellschaft von Kompromissen. Trink Alkohol, trink Bier, aber alkoholfrei. Isst Chips, aber die Diätvariante. Irgendwie kauft ihr Käse, aber nur den Fett freien. Ist das dein Kompromiss? Also ich habe sowas nicht in meinem Kühlschrank. Da, finde ich, braucht es einfach eine Strömung in der Gesellschaft, die gegen den Kompromiss ist, die sagt, wenn schon ungesund, dann so fucking ungesund und fucking eklig, wie es geht. Und dann auch noch scheiß Arbeitsbedingungen. Coke Zero, ja, Coke Zero ist ein Riesenerfolg, ja, Cola, aber eigentlich nicht wirklich, ja, irgendwie so Zigaretten, irgendwie light oder so. Grösster Erfolg der Welt.
Sind total auf dem Vormarsch, diese so eigentlich doch nicht Produkte.
Irgendwie Hybridauto oder irgendwie dann Carsharing.
Ist auch ein Wahnsinniger Erfolg.
Nein, alles scheiße.
Man muss auch in seinem Leben.
Don't be a maybe.
Du weißt, diese Prämissen, du hast einfach alles falsch.
Der Hybridwagen der Prius ist der Meisterkaufteste Wagen der Welt, glaube ich. Ja eben, ich sage ja, dass es gut ankommt. Ich sage nur, dass wir einen Gegenentwurf dazu brauchen. Mein Platz zwei. Die Leute können sich, schau mal, weisst du, früher, auch ohne dass Krieg war, sind Leute den ganzen Tag mit dem Säbel rumgelaufen, weil es gut sein konnte, dass sich irgend so ein Typ, den du dumm angeguckt hast, zum Duell, zum Tode rausgefordert hat.
Du konntest einfach sterben. Einfach, weißt du, da war noch alles auf dem Spiel. Da gab es kein, ja, Gewalt, ja, ist nicht so gut, ja, und wir sollten ja erstmal vielleicht Drohnen hinschicken und wenn die nicht, nein, nein, da gab es einfach auch die Fresse den ganzen Tag. Ja, da stand noch was auf dem Spiel, ja, da konntest du die Haustür verlassen und du konntest sterben.
Und heute, nein, wir müssen alle den Helm tragen, Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wo ich jetzt hingehe mit der Anekdote. Auf jeden Fall, wir müssen den Helm tragen, wir müssen irgendwie Finanzpakete. Ach weiss, ich weiss es doch nicht. Ich mag Burger King, ich mag die Burger. Und ich finde, Burger King haben einfach fucking gute Pommes. Das muss man auch immer sagen. Mein Plan zwei ist Backwerk. Och, ey, du bist so scheiße. Allein an der Top fünf kann man einfach merken, dass du ein Riesenarschloch bist. Weißt du, wir reden hier von, du machst es auf und dann kommst du mit, ja, deutschen Bäckerei und Backwerk ist ja furchtbar. Backwerk ist so scheiße. Backwerk ist so scheiße. Ich war heute Morgen seit langem mal wieder im Backwerk,
habe mir was zu essen geholt.
Und ich habe mir zwei Laugenbrötchen geholt und die Cola.
Und selbst die Cola hat scheiße geschmeckt.
Selbst die Cola war scheiße.
Und die beiden Laugenbrötchen waren locker einen Tag alt.
Die habe ich mir morgens geholt, die waren locker einen Tag alt.
Die waren so trocken und so, schon ähnlich zusammengefallen, wie wenn man ein Brötchen einfriert und wieder auftaut. So ganz seltsam haben die geschmeckt. Aber die Bedingung ist doch, Selbstbedienung macht alles schlechter. Alles, was gut war, ist durch Selbstbedienung nicht mehr so gut. Ja, genau. Und so ist es doch einfach. Allein, dass Leute schon mal angefasst haben könnten, macht es schlecht. Ja, aber ich mag tatsächlich Selbstbedienung, weil ich irgendwie socially awkward bin und nicht gerne mit Menschen interagiere. Deswegen finde ich das eigentlich ein ganz gutes Thema und ich bin da tatsächlich auch ab und zu, weil man auch immer das Gefühl hat, man kriegt schnell seine Sachen. Man muss nicht warten an der Reihe. Genau, ich bin auch sehr ungeduldig. Am Ende ist es komplett falsch und vor allem, ich mag nicht die Situation, dass du, wenn zum Beispiel irgendwie so eine Bäckerei leer ist und du gehst rein und du weißt
aber nicht direkt, was du willst und du stellst
dich erst mal vor die Theke und dann wirst du
sofort gefragt, was hätten sie gerne, aber du weißt
es einfach nicht und du denkst dir, ah,
Streuselkuchen oder Kirschkuchen oder
vielleicht der Amerikaner, aber du weißt es nicht,
du musst sofort antworten. Oder ein Ei.
Oder ein Ei und dann meistens gehst du
dann direkt wieder, weil du
einfach nicht entscheiden kannst, aber bei Selbstbedienung hast du das Problem nicht, da kannst du dich so lange Zeit nehmen, wie du willst. Mein Platz eins ist Subway. Verdammt, meiner auch! Yay, der Gewinner ist Subway. Das war ein persönliches Ende, Subway ist das Beste, mal ganz ehrlich. Und ich sag dir jetzt mal ganz kurz, ja, meine drei Regeln für das perfekte Sandwich.
Aber jetzt kommst du erst mal, es war ein Teaser, war ein Teaser, du kommst. Also ich bin der Meinung, also ich hole mir immer Italienbrot, 30 cm, mit Turkey-Ham-Bacon-Melt und der Knoblauchsoße. Salat, kaum was, ich nehme Blattsalat, ein paar Oliven und normale Gurken. Ich betone Normal normale Gurken, wenn eine Gewürzgurke mein Sandwich berührt, fliege ich über die Theke und schlage der Bedienung in die Fresse. Es ist wirklich toll, du kannst, du hast, es ist purer Individualismus, du kannst alles, was auf deinem Sandwich ist, auswählen, du kannst selbst das Sandwich an sich, das Brot auswählen, du kriegst noch einen schönen Keks dabei, in einem Menü, was nicht zu teuer ist, mit einer Cola dabei, es ist toll, du kannst es nachführen, die Cola, es ist Wahnsinn.
Und du bist einigermaßen schnell dran, die Läden sind schön eingerichtet.
Und es gibt eine gute Punktekarte, es gibt eine gute Punktekarte, hast du die Subway-Punkte-Karte?
Nein, ja doch, hab ich auch, die musst du dir auch nicht besorgen.
Oh, die musst du dir auch nicht besorgen.
Doch, hab ich auch, ich hab schon ein Heißgetränk umsonst bekommen.
Ja, aber du weißt, du hast nicht irgendwie so einen Zettel, der zeitlich bedingt ist und gewinnende Reise nach XY, nein, das ist einfach knallhart eine Karte, die hast du in deinem Geldbeutel und dann piepst du das immer ab an der Kasse und kriegst einfach Punkte und dann irgendwie nach einem Monat sagt der, oh, sie können das auch kostenlos haben. Ja klar, warum nicht, zack, bumm, kein Bullshit, fertig, meine drei Regeln für das perfekte Subway Sandwich. Warte mal, noch gut, dass es mir mal angeteasert,, nämlich noch was gut. Fuck, ich habe es vergessen.
Gut, meine drei Regeln für das perfekte Subway-Sandwich.
Regel Nummer eins.
Frischkäse.
Nein.
Auf gar keinen Fall Scheibenkäse.
Anfängerfehler ist für mich immer ein Zeichen, dass die Leute keine Ahnung haben.
Und achte mal drauf, wenn du sagst, ich möchte Frischkäse, dann kriegst du so ein anerkennendes von der Bedienung, weil die genau weiss, dass du Ahnung hast, was ein richtig gutes Sandwich ist. Regel Nummer zwei, nicht tosten, auf gar keinen Fall tosten. Das kann man sagen? Sandwiches darf man nicht tosten. Das kann man sagen? Dass Subway irgendwann gesagt hat, die Leute mögen das, geht einfach davon aus, dass sie es haben wollen. Oder es ist einfach nur Faulheit. Auf jeden Fall, auf gar keinen Fall tosten. Und zwar, das macht die gesamte konsistente Sandwiches kaputt. Zweitens, Sandwiches müssen kühl sein. Ich will keinen Burger, ich will keinen Steak, ich will ein Sandwich. Das ist was Erfrischendes, was Knackiges. Das geht ja schon in die Salatecke. Ich will mich danach gut fühlen, ich will mich danach auf, frischen. Sandwiches, der Salat von Floretin.
Das geht schon in die frische Wohlfühlecke, da will ich nichts Warmes dabei und es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als warme Frischkäse. Ganz kurz, bevor die letzte Regel kommt, es ist nämlich so, du kannst den Laden auch verarschen und das finde ich ganz toll, wenn man den Laden auch, das ist ein menschlicher Laden, der auch ein bisschen versagt, dem ich manchmal... Er hat Schwächen, er hat Schwächen. Die haben haben manchmal so Sachen, die haben so Angebote, es geht um den Sub des Tages. Und ich habe wie gesagt, ich höre mir immer Turkey, Ham und Bacon und dann haben die zum Beispiel haben die Turkey, Ham als Sub des Tages. Das gibt es dann wesentlich billiger. Und dann kannst du den Laden verarschen und du kannst deins trotzdem haben, indem du das nimmst plus Bacon. Das ist nämlich insgesamt billiger als das, was sie anbieten. Und dann habe ich die überlistet und die hat mir natürlich erst gesagt, nee, das geht nicht. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja klar geht das. Wirklich? Ja, aber dann habe ich gesagt, ja klar, und dann hat sie mich so augenzwinkern und hat sie gesagt, ja, sie haben ja recht, sie haben uns durchschaut. Und dann kam Konfetti vom Himmel und so, naja, vielleicht nicht. Du bist wirklich die Person, die sich am leichtesten verarschen lässt, weil wenn eine gut aussehende Bedienung, eine weibliche Person, da so... Nehmen wir als weiblich.
Dort gibst du einfach doppelt so viel Geld aus.
Ich bin von allen menschlichen Wesen, die zieht mich in den Band, relativ einfach, ja.
Okay, Regel Nummer drei, wenig Soße.
Ich sage immer aktiv, bitte wenig Soße.
Das sage ich auch.
Weil es gibt tatsächlich, die ballern das voll und vor allem, die hauen das immer in das Scharnier des Sandwiches rein, also in die Falz, glaube ich, sagt man, da wo man zuknickt und zuklappt, da hauen die das rein.
Das ist auch eklig, wenn man das tostet, dann bricht es auch manchmal.
Das heißt, man hat zwei lose Hälften, könnte ich kotzen.
Auf gar keinen Fall, niemals tosten, never ever.
Regel Nummer vier, ganz großer Anfängerfehler ist der Satz mit allem. Wie oft ich das höre, wie oft ich das höre. Eui, eui, eui, Leute, Leute, macht euch nicht lächerlich. Niemals mit allem, auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist wie wenn nur ein Blumenstrauß isst. Das kann nicht funktionieren, das kann nicht gut schmecken, es sind einfach zu viele Impressionen, es sind zu viele Dinge, die gleichzeitig funktionieren, das funktioniert nicht. Das ist wie wenn du irgendwie, du gehst zu einem Konzert und da spielt Geige, Cello, Trommel, Harfe und Sänger gleichzeitig, wer will das denn? Auf gar keinen Fall. Mit der Bassdrum auf dem Rücken und dieser Hyatt hinten drauf, der sich so überall Schnurren hat. Das war geil. Ja, die finde ich wieder beeindruckend. Ich auch. Meine Regel, maximal vier Zutaten. Bei mir sind es generell Salat, Tomaten, Zwiebeln und manchmal, wenn ich crazy bin, haue ich dann auch Gurken dazu, Essiggurken tatsächlich, kommt dann natürlich auf den Hauptbelag und die Sauce an, aber das muss natürlich alles gut harmonieren, aber niemals mit allem, never ever, sag das niemals. So, das war's. Dankeschön, Florentin. Wir sind noch durch. Ja, gerne. Das waren eine Stunde und acht Minuten. Das waren eine Stunde und nicht je nach wie viel wir schneiden. Hat sich wesentlich länger angehört. Ja, das war heute, war heute, war heute, ach, ging doch eigentlich. Ja. Nächste Woche reden wir nochmal über Magnete, weil ich gerade welche in meiner Hand habe, weil ich die gefunden habe gerade und weil es echt mich immer wieder fasziniert, wenn ich Magnete sehe.
Ja, das wird noch, glaube ich, ein langanhaltendes Thema für uns bleiben. Vielen Dank an alle Leute, die Kommentare geschrieben haben, wir nehmen uns natürlich zu Herzen, diese Folge wird wahrscheinlich, wie es schon merkt, wesentlich lauter sein als die anderen. Vielen Dank an Jan und alle anderen, die natürlich auch schreiben können, was wir für Folge 10 machen sollen, was würdet ihr euch wünschen und vielleicht, wenn wir wirklich genug Einsendungen bekommen, können wir ein cooles Best aufmachen, was waren eure Lieblingsstellen, eure Momente, wo ihr wirklich lustig heiter wart, wo, sag ich mal, dann Emotionen auch zustande kamen, was waren das für Momente, ansonsten vielen Dank an Stefan Titzel, dass du dir heute wieder die Zeit genommen hast und ich hoffe, die nächste Folge kommt schneller. Wir wollen jetzt wirklich einen regelmässigen,
wöchentlichen Aufnahmerhythmus etablieren.
Und falls Stefan Titzel nicht wieder irgendwie ein Gewinnspiel geworden hat
oder ein Buchdeal geschlossen hat oder irgendwie sowas,
kommt die nächste Folge, nächsten Dienstag.
Bis dahin.
Macht's gut und bleibt Podcast-UFO.
Keep it Podcast-UFO-ich. Keep it Podcast-UFO.